at kencraft candy canes start their
lives as sixty pounds of corn syrup
seventy pounds of sugar and one and a
half gallons of water simmering in a
vacuum cooker flavors like peppermint
cranberry or hot chocolate are quickly
folded in by hand
next the cooks throw the batch into the
puller
after several minutes of stretching and
folding the syrupy glob turns white and
is the texture of a hot marshmallow
cooks arrange sticky strips of warm
colored candy into striped patterns
they shape the white candy into a log
and stick the stripes to its sides
then the enormous block of candy is
plopped into the batch roller and
travels through a series of sizing
wheels that reduce it to edible
dimensions
a trip through the twist belt twirls the
stripes around the white cane
left intact the candy rope would stretch
1500 feet but a cutting wheel chops it
into 11 inch sticks perfect for shrink
wrapping
kencraft bends all of its candy canes by
hand using cane-shaped molds
it takes about one hour to turn a 115
pound batch into 1600 candy canes
employees like head cook tyson blanco
taste a cane from each batch to make
sure the flavor color and texture meet
kencraft's standards at the height of
the pre-christmas season the kencraft
factory churns out 16 000 candy canes
per day